Andy: I tried to sit back as far as I could
so there’d be a long awkward silence.
Thank you to Dr. Arnn, the platform party,
family and friends.
To the class of 2015, congratulations.
We made it.
Before I begin my speech, I find it appropriate
to brag on behalf of this class to all of
you here, the class of 2015 is the smartest
class ever admitted to Hillsdale College.
As of last night, it is also the most philanthropic.
Last summer the other class officers and I
set a goal for 50% class participation in
our give-back campaign.
According to my count, we have reached our
goal.
Once we have finalized these pledges, several
generous alumni will help us establish a scholarship
for next year’s incoming freshman as a token
of our love for this place.
One more note … Two years ago at RA training,
Dr. Arnn made a deal with Matt O’Sullivan
that if he kept his 4-point, Dr. Arnn would
buy him any book up to a certain amount.
As Matt is too humble to say this for himself,
I feel obligated to remind the good doctor
of this.
Male: He doesn’t remember.
Dr. Arnn: I have to interrupt you.
Matthew, what was the amount?
$100?
I’m losing money like crazy.
Send me an email and remind me, and I’ll
send you the book, or the $100.
I made a bet with Jack Babbott.
He’s going to watch this tape.
He gave a big gift for the chapel, and with
the architect sitting there, and with Rich
Paway sitting there, he said, “You’ll
never build this chapel for this amount.
It’s going to cost four times as much.”
I said, in a rash moment, “I bet you $5,000
to your favorite charity against $5,000 to
mine that we can build it for that.”
I looked at Rich and I looked at the architect,
and they both nodded their heads, and I’m
getting ready to write a check to Jack Babbott
for $5,000.
Now it’s $5,100.
Andy: Thank you, Dr. Arnn.
When I began to write this speech last night
… I’m really glad you all thought that
was a joke.
I considered several different approaches.
After all, what is one supposed to talk about
in a commencement speech?
Should I reflect on the last 4 years here?
Reminiscing about the highlights of my experience,
and attempt to generalize them so that everyone
might identify.
Not to say that there’s anything wrong or
at all inaccurate about remembering those
nights when the cell phones go silent, the
lap tops are shut tight, and the conversation
amongst friends soars far and wide.
After all, it is true that most of us, if
not all of us, have had those experiences.
That is a good thing.
This is a commencement address.
For a while now, I have found it odd that
we called the graduation of seniors in the
spring commencement.
Dr. Ward pointed this out.
Commencement refers to a beginning.
To make a start or enter in upon something.
Yet, we are concluding our education here,
and our time has come to an end.
Of course many of you probably want to respond
with, “But our education never ends.”
To which I would respond, “You’re right.”
Now shut up, I’m giving the speech.
Why did we name the ceremony marking our departure
from this school, this place and these people,
in terms of a beginning?
I had a theory.
Commencement is an attempt to give this moment
a particular significance.
In a conscience manner, we want this moment
of transition to be one of hope and of promise,
a setting out from home and confidence enjoyed
towards some glorious fate.
This day is the first day of the rest of our
lives, and 4 years here have prepared us to
meet it with bright eyes and full hearts.
If only that were true.
In order to make us even more self-conscious
about what is happening right here, right
now, I’ll tell you how I’m actually feeling.
I am terrified.
The last time that I was this terrified was
1,350 days ago.
August 28th, 2011, in our freshman convocation.
I’ll be honest with you, like many here
today, I had not wanted to come to Hillsdale.
In fact, it was my last choice.
Some of you, including my family, knew that.
Until now, I have never told anyone the real
reason why.
It wasn’t because of pride or stubbornness,
or some other pretended thing.
I didn’t come to this school because I was
terrified.
Terrified to fail, terrified to succeed, terrified
of the unknown.
This college is hard.
What we do here is difficult from beginning
to end without exception.
The worst part is that it is completely up
to us to do it.
Sure we have the support of so many wonderful
people, but the fundamental responsibility
lies with us.
The words of Albert Camus, from Dr. Jackson’s
Great Books class come to mind.
I didn’t know that freedom is not a reward
or a decoration that is celebrated with champagne,
nor yet a gift, a box of dainties to make
you lick your chops.
No, it’s a chore on the contrary, and a
long distance race.
Quite solitary and very exhausting.
At the end of all, freedom is a court sentence.
That’s why freedom is too heavy to bear,
especially when you’re down with a fever
or are distressed, or love nobody.
1,350 days ago we stood together at East Lawn
and at the prompting of Dr. Arnn, we faced
our parents and loved ones, hugged them and
walked up to that hill to find those mentor
groups we now laughingly remember, and we
begin our journey.
Today, 1,350 days later, we find ourselves
together again.
Today, I’m still terrified.
Terrified to fail, terrified to succeed, terrified
of the unknown.
Terrified because I’m about to leave the
best friends for which a man could ever hope.
Last year Josh Andrew asked on this occasion,
“Was it worth it?”
This year I ask the question, “Is that … Whatever
we are leaving this for, worth it?”
My answer is simple, “Yes and no.”
No because a few of us … Just a few of us,
will ever have another chance to study these
great things, to spend our days in leisure
and contemplation, and enjoy the immediate
presence of friends engaged in the same activity
of soul.
Not to mention that if we were to continue
all of the stupid things we’ve done here,
most of us would live in boxes without a prospect
of a real job.
I say, “Yes,” that whatever is out there
is worth leaving this for, because we were
never meant to stay here.
The hard truth of this college is that we
live and learn here for a short time, during
which we are formed and molded to live in
the world.
We are called from here to love and to teach
others, to show them the beauty that we have
been shown, to suffer and struggle, and do
the difficult activity of living.
Often it will be thankless.
Often, it will be suffering.
Always though, it should be joyous.
We are called and we must respond.
The funny thing about what we were doing here
today is that no matter how hard we try, no
matter how flowing our robes are, or how many
pictures we take, we cannot give this day
meaning.
That isn’t to say that today isn’t significant,
because in a very real way, this is the most
significant day of our lives.
For the first time in 4 years, we are gathered
together in one place.
We have all grown and flourished in a variety
of astounding ways.
This moment is not significant because of
the robes or the pictures, or because we want
it to be.
The significance and overwhelming meaning
of this moment right here right now is not
the result of our conscious choice to make
it so, but comes from all our experiences
until now.
Now we stand at the end of this journey, staring
into what may seem to be an abyss.
This abyss should not terrify us but give
us hope.
Because in its darkness is not futility and
nothingness, but endless possibility for greatness.
The unknown is just that, unknown.
We can only choose how we greet it, with fear
and trembling, or with wonder.
I return to the words of Camu.
“At the end of all freedom is a court sentence.
That’s why freedom is too heavy to bear,
especially when you’re down with a fever,
or are distressed, or love nobody.”
I think that this is right, because after
4 years here, we have found freedom to be
a chore.
It has been a long distance race, at times
quite solitary and very exhausting, and far
too heavy to bear.
This is the fate to which we have dedicated
ourselves, and our commitment to this college
and to each other.
Here at the end of it all, this realization
is the moment to which our education has led
us.
To recognize the difficulty of what we have
chosen to do, and not merely to face it, but
to thrive in the face of it.
We have not simply overcome suffering.
We have been formed by it for a future far
more glorious than any we can conceive.
We need only look back at those men and women
who helped raise us, our parents, for a model
of this.
Consider what it means to bear a child.
Bringing into this world new life.
A helpless and vulnerable person for whom
you are wholly responsible.
This burden is terrifying, but they are here
today, not because of fear for responsibility,
but out of love for the life that they have
helped form, and in the process been formed
by.
They recognize the beautify of this moment.
Not because it isn’t a moment without strife
and despair, but they recognize the beautify
of this moment, because they have persevered
through those things.
They have learned to love that which is true
and good.
From this moment forward, we will share in
this beauty, and not because it isn’t suffering
or pain or struggle, but because through those
things, our hearts and souls have been formed
to a greater love of that which is good and
beautiful.
After all, one sees clearly only with the
heart.
Anything essential is invisible to the eyes.
Today I thank God and I thank all of you,
because we know that this freedom we undertake
is not too heavy.
We love just as we are loved.
We have the people around us today, our family,
our friends, and each other, to thank for
that.
As we gather here together again, I have faith
this love will abide.
Through it, we will know beauty.
Through it, we have a hope that leads us beyond
the confines of this world.